-My first guests are
the co-anchors
of "Weekend Update"
on "Saturday Night Live,"
which returns this Saturday,
with host Chris Rock and musical
guest Megan Thee Stallion.
Let me introduce, please...
[ Drum roll ]
Michael Che!
[ Applause ]
-♪ Michael Che and Colin Jost ♪
♪♪
♪ Sit on down,
talk to the host ♪
-Thank you for being here.
Thank you.
♪♪
-Yeah!
And he's also
a "New York Times"
best-selling author.
Please welcome Colin Jost,
everybody!
-♪ Michael Che and Colin Jost ♪
[ Applause ]
♪ Sit on down,
talk to the host ♪
♪♪
♪ From a distance,
you will sit ♪
[ Applause and laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Thank you for being here.
This is fantastic.
-Thanks for having us, man.
-Yeah, this is cool.
-Yeah, this is nice.
-Thank you for being
our first...
[ Laughter ]
...two-person in-studio
guests, you know?
Uh...
I'm sorry.
Colin, I'm sorry.
I just --
You -- I mean, you...
[ Laughter ]
Do you -- do you feel
far away?
-I don't feel far away.
I -- I am farther away.
I'm a lot farther away.
-Yeah, well, this is for
protocol and all that stuff,
so I just, you know...
Can you --
-I can't hear anything
you're saying.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for coming
on the show, appreciate it!
-Yeah, anytime, man.
[ Laughter ]
-New normal!
-Uh, yeah.
-We're back in 30 Rock.
-Yeah, man, this is exciting,
dude.
-I think I saw you
at the tests
when we were doing all the,
uh, nose swab real quick
the first day we were, but --
How's it like working six feet
apart from each other?
-I love it, I owe a lot
of people money.
[ Laughter ]
Nobody can get it from me.
-Just enough apart, yeah.
-It's perfect.
-Are they making
changes to 8H?
What's happening on Studio 8H?
-We haven't really been in yet
and seen what it is, right?
We had our table read.
-Yeah.
-What was that like?
-Well, we have 20 cast members
in our show right now,
and they have to be
six feet apart.
So 20 times 6 is probably
like a thousand.
I don't know.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you're in a table read
and you're hearing voices
and you're like,
"Who said that"?
-Yeah.
-You're like looking around.
-No way.
-It's a great time for crew
to yell stuff,
because people will be like,
"I guess they're just
in the cast. It's fine."
-Yeah, it feels like you're
listening to a podcast.
You just --
you don't see anybody.
-"No, we're all here," yeah.
-It's great. It's kind of cool.
-That's bizarre.
-It is, but it's, you know.
-What will the audience
look like?
-What are you guys talking
about over there?
-We're talking about
"Saturday Night Live"!
-Oh, that's great.
-Coming back this weekend.
-That's great.
-I was like,
what is the audience
going to be like?
-White.
-No, no --
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no.
-To start with,
they're all white.
-No, no, no, no.
-I don't know if you're
a fan, but...
[ Laughter ]
-Everybody enjoys that show.
But, I mean, is it going to
change the style for "Update"?
Are you gonna still do it the
way you guys have been doing it?
Well, you got to be safe.
-It's a maximum capacity of one
at the desk.
-Congratulations, Colin.
Yeah, we get "Update"
with Colin Jost.
-Sorry.
-I'm all for it.
[ Laughter ]
As long as I get paid
the same, it's fine with me.
No, it should be fun.
I think it's actually
more fun.
Rules make comedy fun,
When there's things you can't
do, when there's kind of
loopholes, that's when you start
to really get creative,
and I think the show is kind of
the perfect place for that.
-Yeah.
-That was like
the political answer.
-No, that was a great answer.
I agree with you.
I love rules.
[ Laughter ]
-I love rules.
-I do, I love it, because
I like to break them.
I go, yeah, go ahead,
tell me what I can't do,
and I'll find a way something.
-Yeah.
You have the best host
for the first show back,
and it is Chris Rock.
And I heard --
We had Chris on the show
and he told me
that you guys had to
actually go to his house
and convince him.
-Oh, yeah.
We literally went
to Chris Rock's house
to tell him to do "SNL,"
and it was very --
It felt like that scene
in "The Godfather,"
remember when Tom Hagen
goes to tell the guy
to put the dude in the movie?
-Yeah.
-I've never seen
"The Godfather,"
but someone told me
it was similar.
[ Laughter ]
I might have gotten
bad information, Jimmy.
But...
-Tom Hagen.
That's a deep cut.
-Oh, yeah, but that's
what it felt like.
I was like, literally like,
"How could you not --
You got to do it, man.
It's New York City.
We're back. It's 30 Rock.
You got to come home
and we got to make people,
you know, feel good again."
-Yeah.
The country wants this.
The country needs it.
I will be watching it.
I cannot wait.
More with Michael Che and
Colin Jost when we come back.